yeah her harbours interesting like I
don't feel anything towards it but it's
like we have our own Pearl Harbor 9/11
is our Pearl Harbor mm-hmm
isn't that special oh it was similar in
many ways correct well but similarly in
French civilians weren't here's the
difference between Pearl Harbor 9/11 yet
is they attack civilians and they used
our own equipped things against us right
and um it was just more devastating I
think 9/11 yeah 9/11 was is a worthy one
that it was a doozy it really was it was
a doozy
yes yeah I think that's what Bush said
he's like boy that was a doozy
how old were you when 9/11 I was in high
school I remember my specific age but or
maybe I was even middle school I didn't
even you know comprehend what was going
on I was homesick
my brother's like hey airplane just hit
the World Trade Center and I was like oh
[ __ ] cares you know I was sleeping
was like 8:00 a.m. all right then I get
up and like the second one hits the
tower and I was so when thinking back
I'm stricken by how uh I was really just
didn't care about yeah you're a pathetic
I just put on cartoons yeah I went on
with my day
yeah I mean you're a kid though yeah
you're a kid as a kid but it's just it's
it's for me I was working at Magic East
oh yeah but still early did it affect
you well Andrew Daley who was also on
MADtv his cousin was on one of the
flights oh right so when I showed up to
work it was obvious like Andrew wasn't
there for like a couple of weeks and it
was pretty brutal man you know um I
remember going to the comedy store the
next day and we had three comedy rooms
open and in each copy room there was a
riot a riot
people would just fistfight in calm it
there was a like yeah people just
punched be the [ __ ] I was like wait what
was the conflict the conflict was people
were like they
did you know you know when something bad
happens in in the world right and you go
to the comedy club you can feel it in
the audience you can feel it with the
performers it's just not really a good
place to be because because I
commandeered and it's an emotional an
emotional place and you you get it
somebody like who I think one of the
best comics in the country which is
against this kid a Rick Ingram or Ari
Shaffir one of these times and they will
just say things right just to shock
people or whatnot it'll it it'll just
ignite bad time yeah it's a bad read
about yet exactly right so that night I
remember it was just so [ __ ] awful
that uh and it was terrible
[Music]